[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo ravi de vous
retrouver pour un tour d'horizon de
l'actualité de la semaine dans le
département tout de suite les titres de
ce vendredi et 25 janvier
cinquante mille passages par an en
moyenne l'hôpital privé de l'ouest
parisien est le deuxième service
d'urgences privé d'île de france il a
agrandi son service des urgences pas de
hausse d'impôts des dépenses de
fonctionnement maintenu et une volonté
d'investissement c'est ce qu'il faut
retenir du budget des yvelines voté ce
matin par les conseillers départementaux
non son débat sur la pression fiscale
premier forum de l'emploi à guyancourt
neige dans les yvelines ou encore
tension à la verrière comme chaque
vendredi coup d'oeil sur l'actualité de
la semaine avant de débuter les chiffres
ont été révélés ce vendredi le chômage a
reculé au quatrième trimestre 2010 hui
dans les yvelines - 1,4 pour cent dans
la catégorie à une diminution
équivalente à celle de l'île de france
le conseil départemental a voté à
l'unanimité le budget 2010 9 ce vendredi
25 janvier un budget de près d'1 5
milliard d'euros avec des dépenses
d'investissement dépassant les 419
millions d'euros consacrés au
développement du territoire au niveau
des transports des collèges ou encore
dans des projets deux communes et un
débat à propos de la fiscalité avec des
amendements déposés par yves vandewalle
pour baisser le taux de la taxe foncière
tous ont été rejetés écoutez yves
vandewalle conseiller départemental et
le président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier à ce propos mais
amendement il avait essentiellement pour
but de réduire le poids de la fiscalité
que nous avions augmenté très fortement
en 2016 et je souhaitais que l'on en
fasse un premier pas vers les
contribuables qui aujourd'hui demandent
plus de pouvoir d'achat et ce en
réduisant des dépenses
z'ont superflu je n'étais pas d'accord
sur le report de ses investissement là
et je concert c'est toujours dangereux
de s'en prendre à l'investissement parce
que l'investissement il s'adresse aux
entreprises c'est donc de l'emploi de
l'emploi privé nous avons décidé parce
que nous arrivons à tenir nos dépenses
de fonctionnement
donc les pinces de personnel toutes les
dépenses du quotidien nous les
maintenons même niveau même nos bébés
sont très légèrement par rapport à
l'année précédente donc on fait des
économies malgré des charges toujours
accrue par l'état et bien maintenant
notre fiscalité c'est à dire il n'y aura
pas de poche du taux de fiscalité du
département la sécurité enjeu important
pour les citoyens hier après midi s'est
déroulée la cérémonie des voeux auprès
des acteurs de la prévention et de la
sécurité à saint quentin en yvelines le
président de l'agglomération jean michel
fourgous était entouré de plusieurs
maires des communes voisines mais
également des organismes et services
destinés à la sécurité la police
nationale et municipale la gendarmerie
mais aussi des agents de sécurité privés
ou encore des services sociaux étaient
présents durant cette cérémonie jean
michel fourgous est notamment revenu sur
le dispositif de sécurité mis en place
lors de la ryder cup avec ses 3000
caméras de surveillance et drones la
sécurité demande de nouveaux moyens
technologiques sur laquelle saint
quentin en yvelines travail écoutez le
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
la sécurité c'est quand même une des
premières attendent vraiment des
français et là dessus il faut que l'on
donne notre contribution avec les très
belles grosses entreprises que nous
avons que ce soit airbus sécurité
défense thales si toi et de défense
safran atos plus les plusieurs centaines
de pme qui sont des spécialistes de la
sécurité qu'il s'agit de faire
travailler tous ces gens là pour bien
sûr que ça profite à anneaux nous nos
acteurs de la sécurité
elles sont plus nombreuses en cette
période hivernale les chutes sur les
trottoirs glissants conduisent de
nombreuses yvelinois aux urgences à
l'hôpital privé de l'ouest parisien de
trappes le service à d'ailleurs été
rénovés afin de mieux prendre en charge
les patients immersion avec aurélie rose
bonjour monsieur
alors qu'est ce qui vous arrive
de tordu la cheville ce matin pas de
fracture heureusement pour ce patient
admis aux urgences de l'hôpital privé de
trappes il devra néanmoins immobilisé sa
cheville pendant près d'un mois les
enfants sont assez fréquentes
traumatisme de sport traumatisme par
lissade actuellement le que les
intempéries avec plus de cinquante mille
passages par an le service des urgences
a été rénové en juin dernier la capacité
d'accueil a été augmentée l'accueil des
patients a été repensé afin de réduire
le temps d'attentes nous agissons sur
toutes les étapes de la prise en charge
à savoir de l'accueil administratif
jusqu'à la sortie du patient l'ensemble
par l'infirmier d'accueil et
d'orientation et la mise en place chez
nous depuis l'année dernière d'un
médecin d'accueil et d'orientation des
écrans permettent d'en savoir plus sur
les délais d'attentes en traumatologie
en médecine une salle de radiologie est
au coeur du service des urgences ce qui
permet aux médecins de rendre leur
diagnostic plus rapidement exemple avec
cette patiente qui a glissé sur une
plaque de verglas en se rendant à son
travail donc là ce qui se passe c'est
que vous avez un traumatisme du poignet
avec une fracture
qui est un petit peu déplacé
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est que je me
rende un avis à l'orthopédie ce sos
mains ça peut nécessiter une petite
butte révolution blocs opératoires des
urgences rénové qui permettent donc une
meilleure prise en charge des patients
plus nombreux en cette période hivernale
et nous devions recevoir en invités et
romain marieuse hulu hasseni médecin
urgentiste à l'hôpital de trappes il a
eu finalement un imprévu d'ordre
personnel on passe donc tout de suite au
reste de l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
ça ne vous a pas échappé il a neigé
mardi dont les yvelines il est tombé
entre 3 à 5 cm de neige météo france
avait placé le département en vigilance
orange le reportage de michael et demi
d'euros
la neige a fait son grand retour ce
mardi 22 janvier dans les yvelines entre
1 et 5 cm sont tombées dans la matinée
sur le département cette saison
c'est bah ouais ça faut pas que ça
continue trop mais bon bah c'est comme
ça quoi bon marché oui pour marcher sur
alger nommé jardin jeu ça duo voix à moi
d'autres au contraire n'était pas aussi
enthousiastes à c'est très très
compliqué c'est très dur fin on n'arrive
pas à avancer fin du coup c'est un peu
le bordel faut aller fois les failles
très doucement fonds faut faire
attention au choix il ya cessé ça glisse
beaucoup fait pour faire attention aux
freins faut pas freiner fort faut
freiner tout doucement des
recommandations qui s'appliquaient
également aux voitures certains
automobilistes yvelinois n'ont pas pu
éviter les dérapages dans les virages le
trafic était notamment difficile sur les
petits axes routiers 1 ça glisse
beaucoup je viens juste de versailles là
et à 10 alors ça va
pour rendre la circulation la plus
praticable possible sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines 12 déneigeuses
ont réalisé chacune entre 30 et 40 km
d'intervention sur les routes les
opérations ont débuté à partir de 11
heures après une première sortie de
prévention dans la nuit c'est la journée
exceptionnelle puisqu'on s'attendait pas
à autant de neige ça sans qu'il nous il
faut qu'on puisse déneiger pendant que
les véhicules ne soient pas là donc
c'est pour ça forcément en détermine des
fois des tranches horaires qui sont
peut-être pas comprise par là à part la
population mais en fait on prend des
tranches horaires c'est tout simplement
pour pouvoir déneiger pendant qu'ils
aient moins de circulation et les
déneigeuses devrait de nouveau sortir
dans les prochaines heures de nouvelles
chutes de neige sont attendues dans la
nuit
et malgré la neige guyancourt organisé
mardi son premier forum de l'emploi
particularité les recruteurs étaient des
agences d'intérim des offres dans les
secteurs de la restauration du bâtiment
ou encore de la logistique était proposé
aux candidats le reportage d'aurélie
rose
depuis plusieurs mois à ce dîner
originaire de lui en cours est à la
recherche d'un emploi après plusieurs
expériences dans la vente il est
néanmoins ouvert à toute proposition que
pourrait lui présenter cette agence
d'intérim alors mon cv à l'après un peu
les informations qu'elle avait besoin de
savoir sur moi énormément voilà j'espère
être au contact et à la fin de la
semaine vraiment comme quand même
l'algérie six agences d'intérim étaient
présentes c'est la première fois que la
ville de guyancourt organise ce type de
manifestation objectif permettre aux
demandeurs d'emploi d'avoir un premier
contact et d'échanger avec les
recruteurs les agences d'intérim nous
ont fait part effectivement de de ce
souci de pouvoir recruter quelques fois
sur des postes soit pas hautement
qualifiés ou mais des postes
effectivement de maintenance et donc
mais y'a tout il ya dans la restauration
il ya énormément de profil qui sont
proposées aujourd'hui les candidats
étaient invités à laisser leur cv auprès
des agences une démarche déjà bénéfique
pour certains j'ai une bonne surprise
bon je me suis inscrite dans toutes les
agences intérim qui correspondait à mon
domaine et le dernier je pensais que
c'était juste une formation un
accompagnement j'y suis allé par
curiosité et finalement ils m'ont
proposé un job ils vont envoyer ma
candidature
un de leurs partenaires et je risque
d'être contactés d'ici une semaine
malgré la neige le forum de l'emploi de
guyancourt a attiré près de 150
personnes deux prochaines éditions
pourrait suivre
est ce le signe de tensions à la
verrière très élus de la majorité ont
créé récemment leur propre groupe appelé
rassemblement des élus pour la barrière
au sein du conseil municipal
ils se disent en désaccord sur certains
projets avec la mère nelly duthu
notamment sur la nouvelle crèche dans le
quartier et d'orly parc les précisions
de nicolas d'andry
des voeux 2010 9 à la verrière avec des
élus absents peut-être le signe d'une
certaine tension très élus ont créé au
sein de la majorité le groupe
rassemblement des élus pour la verrière
le 12 décembre dernier parmi ces élus
l'ancien maire alain ayache contraint de
démissionner en 2016 pour raisons de
santé et de céder son siège à nelly du
tube si secret c'est qu'il ya sur
certains sujets on estime qu'on n'ait
pas entendu qui a un manque de
concertation ou autre chose voyez donc
nous notre démarche n'est pas
comment dirais-je on n'est pas dans une
confrontation nous on est à constructif
on sera constructive jusqu'au bout et
toujours force de proposition ce qui est
sûr c'est que soit l'âge agents
n'avaient pas ces couacs et 7 ces
petites tensions qui aujourd'hui
existait voilà soir j'avais un risque
était forte rassemblée à l'origine le
conseil municipal du 12 décembre dernier
avec une délibération concernant la
nouvelle crèche du quartier orly-parc
des divergences au sein de la majorité
concernant son emplacement qui entraîne
la création de ce groupe sincèrement moi
j'en suis donné un jeu je prends acte de
la création de ce groupe on va se parler
et puis l'idée l'idée quand même et et
de retourner aux élections unis parce
que
ce serait quand même dommage qu'avec
tout ce qui est c'est fait depuis trente
ans sur cette ville
notre opposant politique
se servent de tout ça
dans un panier quoi on espère surtout du
calme que les dossiers plus avancé que
les esprits retrouve la sérénité et la
concorde pour cette nouvelle année
on prépare bien évidemment l'avenir on a
des projets on a une équipe motivée on a
plein dans vie plein d' enthousiasme
al'approche de l'élection municipale de
2020 nelly duthu souhaite avoir des
discussions sans exclure de se
représenter
on prend maintenant la direction de
villepreux l'entrée de la commune
devrait être complètement en
reconfigurer d'ici 2025 le projet
prévoit notamment 250 logements ainsi
qu'un grand parc urbain le reportage de
michael et demi d'euros
c'était l'une des grandes annonces de la
cérémonie de voeux de villepreux le
maire de la commune stéphane mirambeau a
évoqué la création d'un nouveau quartier
en entrée de ville le secteur s'étend du
gymnase alain mimoun au lycée sonia
delaunay au total dix neuf mille mètres
carrés vont être aménagés c'est un
projet qui est important parce que c'est
une zone très emblématique c'est une
zone des centrales au niveau de la ville
et nous voulions réellement que ce soit
la vitrine de villepreux quand on arrive
on veut que les gens se dire c'est ça
villepreux et c'est là que j'ai envie
d'habiter
après un an de concertation avec les
habitants le projet prévoit notamment la
création de 250 logements et un grand
parc urbain avec un kiosque un jardin
partagé une aire de jeux pour les
enfants une grande pelouse donc il y
aura un grand parc urbain on peut
l'appeler même le central park de
villepreux et puis au tour il aura
quelques immeubles très environnementaux
très vert aussi et ça va participer à
l'attractivité de la ville ça va
terminer la ville car ça va être une
zone qui va relier tous les quartiers
entre eux c'est un projet que nous
avions pensé en 2008 on est content de
l'avoir fait aujourd'hui avec tous les
filtres audio des études de faisabilité
financière et environnementale auront
lieu cette année si tous les voyants
sont au vert les travaux devraient
débuter à l'horizon 2020 pour une
livraison définitive prévue en 2025
nous venons de lancer notre rendez-vous
patrimoine tous les quinze jours la
rédaction vous dénichent un lieu
emblématique des yvelines partons à la
découverte de l'arboretum de versailles
chèvreloup un parc situé entre le centre
commercial parly 2 et le château de
versailles qui regroupe près de 2500
espèces d'arbres le site a été acquis
par louis xiv à la fin du xviie siècle
et propose aujourd'hui des visites
un havre de paix à quelques mètres du
château de versailles bienvenue à
l'arboretum de versailles chèvreloup ce
vaste parc de 200 hectares sens 2500
espèces d'arbres venus du monde entier
l'histoire de ce lieu remonte à l'époque
de louis xiv le lien que le château de
versailles c'est que le domaine de
chèvreloup fait partie du domaine de
versailles à l'origine le domaine de
chèvreloup était en fait un domaine
agricole qui a été acquis par louis xiv
à partir de 1685 et dans le but
d'étendre son territoire de chasse donc
c'était un domaine qui était cultivé
encore par des fermiers dans le but de
de fournir des espaces pour le gibier le
site officiellement été attribué au
muséum d'histoire naturelle en 1922 mais
ce n'est que dans les années 1960 qu'il
devient officiellement un arboretum le
public pourra le visiter pour la
première fois en 1979 aujourd'hui les
curieux peuvent observer l'intégralité
du site et y découvrir des arbres de
toutes tailles c'est bien le même espace
que ça pas noël qu'on a classiquement
dans les maisons donc un picea abies
mais c'est une variété antique old men
et celui ci a maintenant 30 ans du plus
petit au plus grand l'arboretum abrite
plusieurs séquoia américain planté entre
1922 et 1925 c'est une espèce la plus
grosse du monde quand on compte sur
volume de troncs sont que les arbres qui
peuvent atteindre 95 mètres dans la
nature alors ici on a des arbres qui
font simplement une petite vingtaine
trentaine de mètres ils sont vraiment
des petits jeunes parce que c'est des
gars qui veulent vivre plusieurs
milliers d'années l'arboretum abrite
également depuis 1982 2000 m² de serres
le site regroupe 5000 plants et fait
partie des quatre plus grandes
structures de ce type en ile de france
ici on reconstitue des climats tropicaux
sec et aride tempérée ou des jungles
luxuriantes
ils ont tous lu toutes les conditions
pour donner leur puissance c'est-à-dire
chaleur et humidité et lumière donc à
partir de ce moment là
vous avez une explosion une explosion de
la végétation qui est digne de son nom
son biotope d'origine seuls des petits
groupes visiter les serres chaque mois
sur inscription les plantes sont
principalement utilisé pour les
recherches ou pour fournir des sites
parisiens ici cheuvreux luz et 90% des
collections végétales du jardin des
plantes de paris donc il ya constamment
des échanges qui se font des plantes
qu'on met à maturité ici et qu'on envoie
après dans les grandes serres du jardin
des plantes de paris mais certains
trésors sont conservées précieusement
ici c'est le cas de ce cactus qu'on
retrouve seulement en amérique centrale
et dans la cordillère des andes
c'est une très belle à agave qui a en
reflet de un peu gris bleuté
un volume assez exceptionnel elle attire
l'oeil d'une façon assez extraordinaire
il s'y plaît aussi à la preuve c'est
qu'il a trouvé sa place et il est tout à
fait
adapté à notre climat versailles et sous
protection en 2018 l'arboretum de
verseilles chèvreloup attiré près de 23
mille visiteurs du mois d'avril à
novembre
un trésor du patrimoine libinois encore
cachées qui gagne à se faire connaître
en mode culture à présent pour sa
nouvelle exposition la commanderie a
fait appel à un photographe artiste
associé jusqu'en 2020 dana ramaen s'est
interrogé sur le corps et le mouvement
une vingtaine de clichés décrypter
décomposer les gestes notamment ceux de
la danse le reportage de mélanie poké
capturé un instant un mouvement 26
clichés sont rassemblés autour de la
danse principalement d'un drame n s'est
attaché à plusieurs compagnies en
résidence ou en représentation avec la
mission danse de saint quentin en
yvelines l'idée c'est de croiser aussi
les artistes que nous programmons et
puis les rencontres se font ne se font
pas et là ça c'est fait
il se trouve que notre partenariat avec
la mission danse ça a été de le faire
que ils puissent rencontrer des
chorégraphes
donc il a assisté à il a rencontré
plusieurs chorégraphies la cité à
plusieurs spectacles
avec ses photographies d'al ram n
entrent au coeur du geste et de
l'impression qu'il laisse son exposition
est le résultat d'une rencontre avec les
équipes de la commanderie
[Musique]
c'était une carte blanche
donc ça fait un an qu'il y travaille et
je ne pouvais pas préjuger du résultat
plastique puisqu'il s'agissait d'
expérimenter corps et mouvements donc ça
pouvait être corps mouvement corps en
mouvement encore c'est lui qui a choisi
comme il a expérimenté plusieurs choses
il ya des choses qui sont floues et des
choses qui sont extrêmement précises
extrêmement nettes et ça donne un
ensemble hyper cohérent et c'est une
partie de la réponse à la question aux
questions qu'il s'est posé d'hui
avec ces clichés le temps semble
suspendu le mouvement las comme une
trace fantomatique pour un autre tour
s'interroger sur l'empreinte qu'on peut
laisser
[Musique]
et pour d'autres idées de sorties rendez
vous sur notre site pour le replay de
l'émission loisirs
[Musique]
l'actualité dans le reste de l'île de
france avec nos confrères de via grand
paris je vous propose aujourd'hui de
s'évader partons à lille d'adam dans le
val d'oise où sera le plus grand port
fluvial d'île de france d'ici 2020
regardez
à l'horizon du premier semestre 2020 ce
plan d'eau devrait ressembler à ça une
marina créé à l'isle-adam sur un ancien
étant ce port fluvial sera le plus
grande île de france une zone de plus de
8 hectares avec un plan d'eau capable
d'accueillir plus d'une centaine de
bateaux de 6 à 20 mètres entouré de près
de 400 logements et d'une dizaine de
commerces un projet qui amènera à la
ville près de 1000 habitants
supplémentaires pour que le projet voit
le jour il fallait qu'il embrasse
parfaitement la vocation de la ville qui
est une ville d'eau qui est une ville
touristique qui est une ville aussi
commerçante et c'est important et bien
d'avoir des projets d'envergure pour
permettre aux villes moyennes aux villes
petites et moyennes que sont les nôtres
et bien de se développer de continuer à
voir des belles infrastructures de
continuer à développer l'activité
commerçante la vie associative voilà
c'est ça la vocation et c'est ça
l'objectif de ce projet pour le groupe
eiffage le maître d'ouvragé et
l'aménageur du projet la création de ce
port n'a pas été un long fleuve
tranquille entre la réticence des
propriétaires à vendre leurs terrains
des démarches administratives complexes
un sous sol pollué transformé en
décharge dans les années 80 et contenant
en plus des obus de la seconde guerre
mondiale la construction du port va
prendre du retard prévu initialement
pour 2016 la marina ne verra le jour que
quatre ans plus tard ce projet
nécessitait dix ans d'études et de
travaux pour pour sortir de terre ça
illustre bien la complexité du montage
des grandes opérations d'urbanisme en
france mon il y en a d'autres opérations
qui sont bien tenues plus simple que
celle là mais il faut être patient et
et acharnée pour arriver à sortir ce
type de projet le projet final ne
comprend pas que la marina sont prévus
des zones piétonnes des pistes cyclables
ainsi qu'une nouvelle zone nature créée
en remplacement de celles détruites par
la construction du port ces zones
humides constitué de marée des espaces
boisés devrait à terme accueillir une
plus grande biodiversité
il vient tout juste de fêter ses 41 ans
et il est à l'affiché cette semaine de
yao le natif de trappes omar sy est
aujourd'hui à l'honneur de notre rendez
vous hebdomadaire ça s'est passé préparé
par wilfrid richie montage romain rousse
fini
[Musique]
187 que la madeleine
et comment tu vas rentrer
s'appelle comment ta ville de jaar
cannelle mois 7 avr je tente
et moi pas croire et l'est où la terre
était un set tu vivais sais pas trop
mais non c'est dit moi je préfère dakar
demain soir d'un avion
[Musique]
oui faire manger
je suis né et j'ai grandi à trappes à
côté oui de saint quentin en yvelines
voilà même si désormais vous vivez à los
angeles pour la vie à quelques instants
pour l'avant première le public
trappistes me suit avec attention oui où
ils joueront bien je reviens souvent ici
à skywest avec mes films est vrai que
j'ai la chance d'avoir des salles
toujours bien pleines avec un piqué kim
aux herbes un superbe accueil chaque
fois et je suis très reconnaissant
omar sy jouer à domicile ce mardi soir
l'enfant de trappes de retour à saint
quentin en yvelines pour la présentation
de son nouveau film de l'autre côté dite
et les gens qui sont proches de moi
valide le film sont contents du film moi
ça me donne aussi la force et le encore
plus de force encore plus de courage
pour le défendre le plus possible
l'ancien trappistes mal à rester aux
côtés du service après-vente fred auront
passé toute une après-midi avec ces
collégiens de montfort l'amaury c'est la
seconde fois que les deux humoristes
s'engage ainsi pour l'association ela
c'est une fête c'est une fête une fête
qui est pas gratuite quoi c'est une fête
qui qui en plus de se placer une bonne
journée de rencontre et quelques enfants
ça permet aussi de récolter quelques
dons pour l'association ela donc ça fait
c'est double effet on fait jamais assez
est-ce qu'il ya des bénévoles qui sont
là et qui le font toute l'année nous le
fait assez ponctuelle mans parce que on
est pris par le travail que voilà on n'a
pas forcément le temps tout le temps
donc déjà ça c'est un engagement lourd
et après il ya des événements à ses
concurrents elle comme comme aujourd'hui
venir le fais avec plaisir quoi je
cherchais mon papier
comme lui vers l'idée d'être la sister
ça vous gêne pas vivre sur des autres
merci et vous qu'en pensez vous savez
quand même capable de travailler j'en
avais l'humour j'aurais tellement que je
suis prêt à prendre les c'est vrai
vous tiendrais pas 200 m
[Musique]
quand on prend un micro à moi omar sy
qui vit à los angeles qui vit aisément
qui qui qui en pose la question sur la
banlieue aujourd'hui j'ai quitté
travailler à 20 ans c'est à moi de vous
poser la question il est déjà là le
problème c'est que si haut c'est à moi
qu'on pose des questions sur la banlieue
on va jamais le résoudre alesi est posée
dans la question les jeunes ils sont là
bas ils n'attendent que ça qu'on leur
tende un micro et qu'on leur donne la
part de
[Musique]
réussite vient quand même leur apporter
un peu de ton expérience ouais c'est
important d'être là c'est important
d'être là déjà pour eux c'est important
d'être là où x
pour papy cdo surtout important pour
nous c'est important pour nous de
retenir et à côté le stade était un
petit peu
et bien c'est
tout ça de ressentir des trucs là il
s'est passé plein de choses qu'on est
ici dans cette salle donc c'est bien
aussi il ya de la peine symbolique a
plein de bonnes raisons maintenir matin
au quartier belle tape ces mots le
sujet nancy g
cette dernière information avant de
refermer ce journal soyez prévoyants
samedi la gare de trappes sera fermée et
toute la journée la sncf rénovent leurs
vêtements des quais afin notamment de
faciliter la circulation des personnes à
mobilité réduite
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo retour
de l'information lundi dans le 7-8
journal dès 18h passer un excellent
week-end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]